hey what is up guys
MK Bhd here and today I was at Google's
event where they revealed the new
nexuses so the flagship hardware to
carry the latest version of their
software Android 6.0 marshmallow and so
this video is your one-stop shop to
everything you need to know about them
so they announced three new devices
today Nexus 5x Nexus 6p and pixel C
alright so while we made Nexus P is the
highest end the successor to the Nexus 6
so I guess what I would call the
flagship the specs are high-end so the
newer Snapdragon 810 chip the audrina 4
3d GPU and 3 gigabytes of RAM and the
design is actually really nice it's a
completely metal body now and it's all
chamfered at every edge still then of
course as Nexus azar but overall a very
rigid solid body that feels high-quality
the camera hump is not nearly as bad as
we thought it would be so that's great
and it's one of the lightest phones of
this size I know it's 7 millimeters thin
and everything but I didn't expect it to
be this light when I picked it up
assuming it was metal it's just 178
grams so the light weight plus the soft
touch finish on the metal and the lack
of curves made it really easy to hold
and while it does have this new big
bright 5.7 inch quad HD AMOLED display
on the front the side bezels stay pretty
thin too so the phone definitely feels
more compact than the well of the old
Nexus 6 it's got that big old Nexus logo
on the back in whatever color you get
and it also has that circle on the back
which is a fingerprint reader Google
calls it Nexus imprint it's supposed to
work in 600 milliseconds or less I have
yet to test it for myself with my own
fingerprint but if it's anything like
huawei's other fingerprint readers it
should be pretty fast and the placement
on the back here was a bit confusing at
first but it actually makes a lot of
sense considering it turns out to be a
pretty good place for your index finger
to rest while I'm holding the phone so
there's a feature that will let you
place your finger on the back while the
phone is still sleeping and it will wake
the phone and unlock it for you right
away just like the oneplus 2 the one
question mark in my head now is just how
cases will address this other than just
cutting a hole in the back but yeah the
Nexus 6p it fills up the spec sheet and
checks a lot of boxes high-end CPU high
end GPU all-metal build big bright HD
quad HD AMOLED display dual front-facing
stereo speaker
years 802 dot 11 AC Wi-Fi lte-advanced
NFC Bluetooth 4.2 USB type-c with fast
charging Thank You a pretty big 3450
milliamp hour battery despite looking so
thin and even a new 12 megapixel camera
with f 2.0 aperture that even without
optical image stabilization was just
ranked the DxO mark number 2 smartphone
camera just below the Samsung Galaxy s6
now I know that having oh is would
definitely still have been preferred it
would have benefited the camera I think
for sure especially with video and for
low-light shots but I was shown some
sample photos in low light from the 6p
that looked pretty good and the 1.5 5
micron pixel size is among the largest
and a smart phone so hopefully this Sony
made sensor combined with improved image
processing in Android M will work its
magic and yeah you've got this you know
pure simple Android 6.0 marshmallow
experience with a new Nexus phone it was
of course super smooth and snappy as you
would expect we got to see Google now on
tap in action so it looks like it takes
a few seconds to work its magic but when
it does work it lets you press the home
button and hold from anywhere to get
contextual information about the text on
your screen there's all kinds of little
improvements like this and the final
version of marshmallow here so improve
permissions management there's less
pre-installed apps and you have the
final Easter egg etc so for me I really
can't wait to test the sky full time and
figure out if the camera and battery
life hold up to the spec but I think if
they do this could be one of my favorite
smartphones of the year it'll start at
32 gigs for $4.99 and then go all the
way up to 128 gigs next up is the LG
made Nexus 5x so this is a more compact
and even more budget-friendly phone and
it can sort of be seen as a successor to
the original Nexus 5 which a lot of
people were asking for a smaller phone
with updated specs that's not huge with
that same soft touch feel but updated
specs to bring it up to speed so that's
basically what this is of course it's
now a plastic body instead of metal but
you get a lot of what's great about the
Nexus 6p from the fingerprint sensor to
the exact same camera optics on the back
to USB type-c and fast charging but it
has the appropriate corners cut to make
it a more budget-friendly option so
Snapdragon 808 chip 2 gigabytes of RAM
27 hundred million power battery and a
5.2 inch 1080p LCD display instead
that quad HD AMOLED so in many ways a
slightly redesigned and in my opinion
cleaner and better looking Nexus 5 and
at its price I seriously think this is a
phone that anyone can consider buying
not just Nexus enthusiasts it starts at
16 gigs so that's a little low for no
expandable storage but that's 379 and
then the 32 version is 429 so that's
right up next to the Moto X pier and the
oneplus 2 but with a potentially much
better camera and larger battery so
again that's potential since I have to
see these tested in the full review now
finally we saw the pixel C C stands for
convertible and to be brief it looks
very familiar basically a 10 inch tablet
that looks a lot like the Chromebook
pixel and a magnetically attaching
keyboard accessory that also looks like
a la película Chromebook pixel so it's
like they split the pixel in half has a
super-bright 2560 by 1800 display and
NVIDIA x1 chip 3 a bytes of RAM and some
bigger stereo speakers on either side
for that crispy audio and then $149
keyboard accessory has some really
powerful magnets in it that allow for
the hinge to be really strong and
actually feel solid like an actual
laptop so this guy will start at $4.99
so a little less expensive I guess then
some other options like it but still
pretty interesting nevertheless so there
you have it the new Nexus family is born
for 2016 like I said I'm personally
pretty pumped about the Nexus 6p I think
it's going to make a pretty good run at
potentially being my daily phone if the
battery life and the camera are as good
as they promised and I was pleasantly
surprised with the 5x fitting in nicely
as a phone that I would actually like
want to recommend to a normal person
which hasn't been the case with a nexus
phone for a little bit either way thank
you for watching definitely leave a
thumbs up if you enjoyed and if you're
excited to see the full review thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
you